foreign
[Music]
with Warner Brothers Discovery cutting
way back on animation and HBO Max
pulling their own shows from the service
any cartoon that survived the purge has
to be great right friends a rich white
guy with a tiny dong right it has
something to do with drugs which I hate
right I spit truth without a filter like
every comedian before hashtag me too
help me
Velma if you love revisiting your
favorite childhood cartoon Yankees but
also hated everything about it hell
a been strapping for a series dripping
with contempt for the audience and the
source material there's no world where
I'm ever solving a mystery in an
abandoned amusement park the crabs
Non-Stop quips about these days under a
Scooby-Doo shaped mask he looks like
Hitler and not just because we compare
everyone to Hitler these days sorry I'm
not a drunk on the verge of losing
custody like every other woman solving
murders these days yes but you hurt her
feelings which is way worse these days
and they would have gotten away with it
too but in this day and age comedy
equals issue plus reference in this day
and age
someone's sexuality unless they're
famous or
funny
or she was the brains behind the Scooby
gang Velma Dinkley was just an everyday
mean white girls with too much money
disgusting now I have to pee in the
shower at school like a weirdo stupid
you talked me out of my flat Earth phase
insensitive now you have Gigi to talk
about boring stuff like your swords and
feelings unreasonable my fault nothing
is ever my fault self-hating like the
dessert course at an Indian restaurant
just forget it horndog in love with a
white bully who treats her like I mean
sure if someone was like want to see a
naked picture of Fred I'd be like like
if your typical Mindy Kaling creation
was a more overt cry for help
I don't have
it break up now Ryan
follow along on needlessly complicated
season-long overlapping Mysteries
Norville and I are pretending to be
Amanda's parents for the next 32 hours
to help my mom remember who took her in
the brains before he strikes again about
velma's desperate search for her missing
mom a killer the source of her
hallucinations her friend's birth
parents her own sexuality and any part
of Scooby-Doo's corpse they haven't
already pissed on what are we son zonks
Keepers Mystery Machine and of course
ganja funny that's all just a framework
for jokes that sound like an AI mixed
Family Guy with blue check Twitter and
somehow didn't kill itself damn city oh
I am so hosting that does no one read my
blog Gigi's juicy Journey please update
your status to Loser across all social
platforms hashtag frafni is the top
trending story you placed your hand on
your verified check mark and everything
welcome back all your favorite things
from Scooby-Doo except for Scooby-Doo
Scooby what did Scooby Do or the Mystery
Machine
jalopy
or Shaggy now he's normal a do-gooding
sin I'm simping for myself funny Fred is
back as a poster boy for White Privilege
is it funny women make 20 less than men
and women of color even less
I can't stop laughing funny and Daphne
she's messed up my mom's love my
impression of my Aunt Cindy I am sad my
husband died funny in a show that takes
its diverse and talented cast and makes
them all cycle between extremely mean
and extremely horny Whatever Gets the
writers to their lunch break sooner or
just make them a grind that works too
good enough
have you ever noticed how TV shows can
be bad and for me like whom Velma does
have you ever noticed how pilot episodes
of TV shows always have more gratuitous
sex and nudity than the rest of the
series constantly according to TV it's
morally okay to deal drugs on TV shows
The Malt Shop owner is always a friendly
black man or a spicy and meatball
Italian if the kids in every teen show
ever can get through a brush with
deranged serial killer in teen movies
whenever a girl needs money a guy sells
something and then blackmails the girl
in the dating him for Norville helped me
get over them in the last episode of my
hallucinations in a series that may not
have too many actual jokes but dang if
they can't pull out some extremely stale
references
exactly what happened to my Vlog about
easy Dr Phil look for the stone that is
as perfect as Woody Allen and Mia
farrow's marriage damn this makes me
think I could bag Don Lemon or do not to
other TV writers that will Delight
everyone from Burbank to North Hollywood
after hearing that I not only feel
emotionally hooked I understand the
stakes of your journey who is this for
so suffer through a show that manages to
somehow make fun of and exemplify
wokeness
being intolerant
and still comes off as kind of racist
Belmont and Norville can look after
their daughter themselves right Norville
[Music]
and wants zero to do with the source
material because it's been done better a
million times already but if you're
wondering why they made this show in
particular just remember the old
internet rule if you can't tell what the
target of the jokes are it's you for
watching it you know what 420 is right
um yeah it's code for adults who still
watch cartoons funny
Scooby Dooby Doo Where Are You The Dog's
nowhere to be found
Scooby Dooby Doo where are you
put down you know that HBO is cutting
shows
don't come back in this cartoon the
point of view is mean and shrill and all
the jokes are hot
that's a fact
Cartoon Network's through slashed into
they canceled all the wrong shows
[Music]
the dodgeballs
story
Ginger Snaps the Fred system flaunt cash
relish and adoration evade sex deceive
and move on it wasn't me it's weird that
there are no mainstream pop culture
references we can use for Russell Peters
because he sells out stadiums all the
time but here we are the millionaire and
his wife Brooklyn six nine not it and
encyclopedia frown
what no
oh God my heart
hey if your friend is having a panic
attack don't try to help them by kissing
them especially if you've never kissed
them before and don't know if they'd be
into that I honestly can't even believe
I'm having to say this out loud
like you almost made me use one percent
of my power
man I do not bother you I did not oh hi
Fred would you do it for a Scooby Snack
would you do it for two Scooby Snacks
yeah